what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey from podcast
one
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone
we just become best friends yep
god every single time i listen to this i
swear i got this endorphins running up
my spine
and i feel it welcome back to another
episode of unwaxed if you've stuck with
us for this long
thank you hi hi how are you welcome back
if you don't know us
i'm sophia i'm sistine and if you do
glad to see y'all welcome we want you
here
before we get into the episode make sure
you're subscribed to our youtube channel
follow us on instagram on wax podcast
twitter on wax podcast
and our own twitters i mean instagrams
and twitter sophia
i don't know we're trying to plug we're
trying to figure this out get it
subscribe like rate comment we need all
of that
yes we appreciate it thank you and we'll
keep providing the best content
out there for you we're trying man we're
doing we're doing we're doing pretty
good
yeah the second time i think we're kind
of i feel like we're
much more eased into it than we've got
the mojo we do
i'm feeling good i think it's the
beginning because when we started this
podcast like we really wanted to make
sure that intro song was
hard in it people were in their car like
whoa all right like some type of bee we
made well thank you will
yes well i still listen to it alone at
home and i'm like man this isn't funny
yes we're like we want you to be in the
gym in the shower
jamming out to it before a date ready to
go yeah
pumped all pregame song it should it's
exciting and we wanted to include all of
that
nice um what are all the lines from
movies that you guys all remember just
to
oh like i remember that i can copy that
i feel like having a legitimate
podcast opening soundtrack makes it
real makes it absolutely real so did you
want to explain to um everybody what we
usually do every week and we're going to
do a week so we're testing out some
some topics some subjects here let us
know if you guys like them or hate them
and we'll stop doing it
yep so we thought it would be fun to do
a wax and wayne of the week starting out
for each episode if you didn't know what
that
is like me i had to google it she found
it we were pretty
wayne proud high and low of the week and
just to sort of recap our week tell you
guys
what's been new with us um sophia i know
you have a good wax in wayne this week
so why don't you
kick us off i'll go on okay well i think
for my wax
so my high is that i am once again
going on another date it's gonna it's
been with someone i'm so happy for you
thanks i know you are i'm just jealous
but i'm really actually happy for you
thank you now i'm excited this is
someone i've been seeing for
um i think almost over a month now since
oh much
more no seriously serious no labels
nothing but you know i always like to
have that opportunity to get out
get ready um but my wane was a dream i
had last night
and can i explain to you what happened
in the stream because it doesn't really
make sense
but it started out great i was in wwe
someone threw me into the ring have you
guys watched wwe it's that wrestling
mania we'll run it back wwe is something
that holds
so near and dear to our heart yeah you
guys have no idea my dad
used to make us watch it all the time
like we know all the heavy hitters
undertaker the big miz triple h
we know uh natalie don't call it steve
austin oh steve austin
um randy orton randy orton oh he's so
attractive we grew up
even what was john cena john cena great
paul colgan like you guys players today
i watched i watched some recent
you know episodes i didn't like i love
it and i have to say
before i'll let you continue yeah but i
have to say that the day i found out
that wwe wasn't real
and that it was scripted and the hits
weren't real
it tore my childhood apart
we died we like actually freaked out we
were so sad i genuinely thought
the story lines were real the hatred
between these people were
the rivals the hits the falls there was
an undertaker just walking around
beverly hills all of a sudden just
resurrecting in the middle of the street
i was like [ __ ]
just comes no yeah yeah so you had a
dream about
dreaming i was stoked about that so all
i remember was running down from like
the bits and pieces
and all of a sudden i get in the ring
and i was fighting the bella twins
which was great but then all of a sudden
i'm trying to swing at them
i realized my hands are oven mitts so
i okay so i was swinging at them i
couldn't land anything they're kind of
laughing because i'm hitting them
and i look down i'm wearing an apron i
have a hat on
and i just get pummeled by these two
girls the entire time so i was kind of
pissed off when i woke up
yeah yeah so that was kind of like wait
because when did you have this dream
last night i had a really sad dream last
night too well
i think it's all the melatonin i've been
smoking yeah you
think about this melatonin is now in a
vape
what are they doing well also i had no
idea
i don't like do e-cigarettes but man the
way that they are incorporating things
to this younger child
it's crazy but it gave me some weird
dreams last night
i was trying to think of a name of what
i would be if i walked in there
like what would be my ring name you know
there's the undertaker there's bella
twins you'd be bambi
no it'd be like you'd be like bambi i
wanna be somebody like like
like you know like cheryl temple like
shirley temple charlton
you'd be bambi i'll tell you spider
cheryl temple
cooking up some not healthy banana bread
i'm hitting my head against the mic
but you're happier by the minute you'd
be bambi because you're klutzy
no but i i was wearing an oven mitt i
was writing a chef's hat i was right
let's move on from this stupid day i
want to know about
your date tonight what are you doing
we're going to dinner and
we are you going to this place in west
hollywood if we're
are we do you know which one i'm talking
about it's the one okay go straight from
the mexican restaurant
mom told me where you're going to dinner
and i'm going to the same place
and i did it okay listen listen i
actually didn't want to tell you
i didn't want to tell you i wanted to
tell you on the podcast
and so here's the thing i didn't want to
tell you because i think this is good
this is not good
this is good i'll tell you why this is
good picture this
okay my reservation's at 7 30. you're
there at 8 o'clock with your day i even
knew what time my reservation was
yes you're there at eight o'clock
imagine
someone sends an appetizer or a drink
to your table and i pretend like it's
from another guy
in the restaurant sent it over all right
to make sh
to make your date feel just a little bit
square me in a seat just a little
insecure
tell me that's not a good idea behind
this one the restaurant's small
we look like twins it's gonna be very
blatantly obvious that
you were he's gonna think i thought you
were invited by me so you can like stalk
him i was gonna wear a wig what am i
supposed to say
and bring a newspaper cece what am i
supposed to say like oh my
sister's here to like hang out in the
same restaurant the same exact time
with me sophia the details will come
later they'll fall into place
the point is will do you think it's
weird
i do think it's weird i also don't want
i think on a thing that's going well
like
ideally you wouldn't sabotage that thing
with she's gonna sewing seeds of
distress
all right well let's see from another
man you know the ego is very brutal in
the beginning we want to be careful
by the way he's gonna be stressed out
not know what to do all right all right
i'll i'll replay it i'll do this i'll do
this
she's still gonna go let me rethink my
tactic what if
i sent a drink from me and then she
doesn't know that i'm there
and he doesn't know that i'm there so
i'm so separate and then she looks over
and
she goes oh my god who sent this drink
and the waiter goes the lady over there
and i like tipped my hat at her
you know it's like a top hat only if
you're dressed like carmen san diego
okay okay so next week we will talk
about it
i'm doing it tonight this is how it's
gonna go so bad
it'll be fun i'm actually a little
excited about you know what if he reacts
in a negative way
then that just already shows me yeah i
ain't got what it got but you ain't got
what i need
i can't even sure go for it that sounds
great she shuts her i need to just shut
down at this point
okay well i want to talk about a little
bit who we're going to bring on this
episode
yeah i'm too excited i can't wait any
longer this man is literally like a
walking encyclopedia to how men and
women
think especially in your early 20s to
early 30s
and just listening to his podcast i've
learned so much from him
and i think we should bring him on but i
also i would just like to disclose to
our listeners
that we will be saying the word [ __ ] an
absurd amount of times
so if this bothers you as tony soprano
likes to say
get the [ __ ] out of here get out of here
how was the accident pretty good
everything's pretty good so let's bring
him on
while his twitter bio reads comedian
actor writer
girl zem suga the people's champ this
philly native is also ladies
biggest nightmare hosting the brutally
honest
yet hilarious podcast advice from a [ __ ]
boy
this is clint coley ladies and gentlemen
thank you for having me wow oh my god
i'm women's worst nightmare okay can i
say a device from a [ __ ] boy
i think women are a little i get it yeah
you have to admit you probably get a lot
of [ __ ] for having a podcast like that
well
i get it i get a lot of [ __ ] for the
name but then finally when people tune
in they're like this is
nothing what i expected but is there
something wrong with being called a [ __ ]
boy
yes there is absolutely wow it's not a
good thing
it's not a good thing so it's just a bad
reputation it's a bad game
yeah right well here's the thing all
right so let's let's let's let's define
where the [ __ ] boy is
so anybody out there who's listening
who's paying attention all right on this
podcast
ladies and gentlemen a [ __ ] boy is the
following a guy
who lies to women to get what he wants
a man who lies to women to get what he
wants give you an example
all right so let's say sophia you say to
me uh let's say
i meet you i like you you like me blah
blah blah right yeah now
i know if i say hey what do you what do
you want right now what are you looking
for right now you're like clint i'm
gonna be honest
uh i want to be in a relationship right
you know i've been i've been single for
about three years
i want to be in this committed
relationship now if i know
i don't want to be in a committed
relationship and i just want to [ __ ] you
right right i'm telling you hey i want
to be in a relationship too
knowing that all i want is to have sex
now once i get that i i don't want
there's nothing i need to do so it's
like emotionally physically everything
you need the parents you'll
meet the friends do all of that you'll
you'll you'll you and then
and then and then say hey i'm not really
ready for this
you know damn well that's not true you
were ready to [ __ ]
just say that see the problem is a lot
of guys we don't give women
the opportunity to just to say that
that's what you want too
right so like let's say now let's say
you know let's say i say you know
you you know let's say you and i meet
you like hey what are you looking for
right now
yeah and i'm going to be brutally honest
i'm like look sophia look i'm i'm not
looking for
for much i'm looking to you know you
come over
hang out hang out it's nothing more than
that nothing more than that i'm saying
yeah we could be friends too
right friends exactly that's right but
it's also giving you the option to say
this is what i want or this is what i
don't want
yeah you know what i'm saying do people
find it offensive though that you're
right off the bat that honest or do
people actually respect that more i
think
in my 30s women respect that more and
the reason why is because i'm not
wasting your time
i was going to say it seems like a lot
of work just to get
to hold on right i feel like people
misdefine what a fuckboy is and they
just think oh fuckboy's an ass hold that
sleep through the one night and just
takes you back no no no if he tells if
he
yeah if he's but if but here's the thing
though if he's saying if you if you
let's say you be like if you had a
one-night stand
that's not a fuckboy right there's
nothing wrong with having a one-night
stand
if you're honest about it yeah if you're
saying like hey like look look this is
what it is like
there's been plenty of times where you
know i'm a comedian on the road you know
what i'm saying so there's been plenty
of times where hey i'm in
new york yeah i don't live here i'm not
traveling back and forth to see you
right let's enjoy the night yeah and
i'll and
if we want to be friends we can but it's
mainly to me
[ __ ] boy and i don't want to get this
deep you know what i'm saying no a lot
of people get deeper
a lot of times like i have this podcast
about advice from a fuckboy because
i kind of want to get it's it's for guys
right telling guys hey this [ __ ] ain't
cool
right it's okay to just save to a woman
this is what i want
right if she don't want what you want
then did that that's it
now let's go a step further than that
too right like a lot of times too also
saying what you don't want so if you say
yo i don't want to be in a relationship
or yo i just want to have sex
your actions have to line with your
desires on top of that
your actions have to line with your
desires like a fuckboy wizard
yeah so like a fuckboy wizard
look at you that's hilarious my mind is
blown but like so
so so so so let's say sophia and i keep
using those examples just because
you know i feel like i have your phone
yes so uh so let's say
i let's say let's say i i find you
attractive and i'm like look
i don't want a relationship i just want
to like enjoy you yeah
bottom line whatever that encompasses
right right you're like clint i'm down
with that blah blah blah totally
but now if i'm doing stuff like
i'm sending you flowers and i'm i'm
leading you to my actions are leading
you to believe
that this is going to be more than what
it is you know what i'm saying right
that's also [ __ ] boy behavior so you're
saying you're not looking for anything
but then also acting like you're about
to date me
right explain that exactly now now there
is a fine line between that i know you
got a question but there's a fine line
between that
because the fine line is is that there's
a fine line between
showing you just basic respect yeah and
going over the top
so basic respect is like if i'm having
sex with you right yeah yes when you
come over my house i'm i'm going to make
sure you eat i'm going to make sure like
yeah
basic [ __ ] like we're not just going to
sit there and [ __ ] man
yeah we're going to talk we're going to
have to yeah we're going to enjoy each
other have a glass of wine let's just
like
yeah yeah exactly but but here's what
i'm not doing either though like i'm not
asking you to be my date to a wedding
i'm not asking you
yeah do you find that a lot of women
expect that after
you have your fun night no i don't think
like in in my 30s i don't in my 20s yes
yes
i was gonna say because in my opinion
you need to train to be a [ __ ] boy
unless
for you was it something just innate in
you
no no no no no no no were you where you
started when the on the podcast so
i'm not so i'm not a fuckboy anymore
congratulations so the podcast should be
called advice from a former [ __ ] boy
that's what it should have been in the
first place right but i say advice from
a [ __ ] boy because i'm gonna be honest
with you it's a provocative topic and
people are gonna tune in
for that for that same reason i'm gonna
say this though because when i first met
you and i was
this was like a couple i don't know how
many months ago yeah was it this year
it was last year i was trying to start
my own podcast it was [ __ ] i failed
you didn't you didn't fail i did come on
what if you carried the show i listened
to the entire thing
but let me ask you this what is what is
failing
okay yeah you know what i i thought i
want to know okay i thought i failed
because
aft even after that no one was really
interested no one was kind of giving me
the call back they just didn't see
the show that i wanted right before so
but you told me
at that day you're like you can start on
your own you can you don't need a people
to back you up
but you also said my my show is called
advice from fuckboy
so you need to do something that gets
just people eye so you're like i like to
be the bad guy
right because that's what cooks people
and so from that
that's why i was like i gotta get my
sister on board and we created the show
unwaxed because that is kind of a yeah
what the [ __ ] is
exactly about 50 of the people do not
like the name which just makes us like
it more
you get do you i mean when you say unwax
or you talk about like
like like like unwaxing your we'll see
so that's what we like it's not for
interpretation because
i i like waxed i like it i like i like i
like i like
you wax stuff i like waxed yeah yeah get
your ladies get
waxed no no no unlocks we're real
natural raw baby
yeah 20. you don't need to do that [ __ ]
anymore you don't need to but then
don't don't but everyone's got a
preference i'm not going down there
[Laughter]
i'm not going down there i'm i'm not
i don't like letting my beard when i'm
eating
you know what solid valley valencia i
honestly
don't blame you i respect the honesty
it's true
i actually want to switch gears because
speaking of you're doing your podcast
doing quarantine and all this stuff and
you're probably also
way more relaxed and like probably
thinking of more content than you
ever did since you have all this time or
maybe not oh just kidding
i'm i'm gonna just be this is are we
allowed to be on wax for this pocket of
course
this quarantine has been the worst [ __ ]
that's ever happened in my life like i'm
not even gonna lie to you and it's not
because of just
like you know i wasn't able to tour um i
lost my grandmother in april
i'm sorry i lost my father also in april
so like
like it's been like and the way i feel
about
my dad is like you know whoever whatever
parent you're
closer with you don't have to say that
on air or whatever but like my dad was
my best friend was your person
so it it it's it's been a very difficult
time because like you don't
because it's hard to come up with
content when you lost somebody like that
you're
yeah like my dad is like like to me he's
everything right
my dad would whoop rocky ass let's get
him in here
but no but like like you're like that's
who about like that's who my dad is you
know i'm excited
so you know it's been it's been a rough
time but like finding so the thing is
though
the way during this time you know you
find new ways to
to be to let out how you feel you know
what i'm saying and stuff like that so
i've been i haven't been that creative
but you know i've been i've been
hanging out with friends like have you
been using dating apps or anything
because i know sister and i've been
talking about that
a lot on this podcast have you all been
dating have you all been dating
we thought it would be funny to join
raya during courtney what is that
oh okay you guys sound like y'all what
is that okay first of all let me ask you
are y'all single you're both
singing yes
here's my theory i think that in
quarantine you should be cuffed
i agree with day it's just makes sense
i'm i'm
bored at home i'm constantly
overthinking things i'm
you know should i reach out to my ex
because i have no other options which is
just
did you yeah yes listen listen
look this listen listen but i regret it
you know
well why do you regret it like did you
get did you get okay oh she got played
why [ __ ] boy see
i gotta see look i'm about to look we're
gonna start a group chat you me and your
sister yeah
yeah we're gonna like you eddie listen
and i'm not saying it's just on air
off air like if y'all got questions i
got answers
and when i say i got answers like i got
answers good i knew so like when you
so one of the things is when you reach
out to a guy right or your ex
yeah and this is for anybody listen to
this when you ladies when you reach out
to your ex boyfriend
know what you want before you reach out
so you don't get played
yeah so like if you're reaching out to
your ex you know like okay you're 20
let's say you know
you're saying to yourself okay i know he
ain't [ __ ] i know
i don't want him anymore i know but he
probably had great baby
it's been a while i need some dick yep
there we go
girl's got needs you got i need some i
need some i need some i need some penis
say that that's it like say that like if
you want that
when you say that normally
one person in that relationship is going
to catch feelings again
so this is where this is where you have
to
like it's all about knowing what you're
getting into
okay all most women who've okay let me
first of all let me go back in the story
i was a [ __ ] boy in my 20s and i've lied
to women to get what i wanted
but the reason why guys lie a lot of
times to get what they want is because
they feel like they can't be honest with
women
we feel like we can't say to women hey i
just i want to just
let's have a night of ecstasy is it
because you think we're going to judge
you we think we think hey you're going
to judge us
and be that you're not going to want to
do what we want you to do at the end of
the day
but because we're so [ __ ] driven in our
20s right like when i got when i when i
turned
30 or i would say when i was like when i
turned like 27 28
i had been over being driven by vagina
because at that point i'm like okay like
you could have great vagina
but if you if you if you get on my
nerves why the [ __ ] are you here
right so like okay so like let's say
let's say you only use let's say
you you wanted to just you just want to
[ __ ] your ex don't stay tonight
don't don't put yourself in position to
to feel like you want to fall in love
with this guy again
right do not stay tonight if you know
you just want dick go over there
get what you need and get this it's an
og
what if okay it's the guy that wants the
relationship again
and you made it clear from the beginning
fun friends
i i want to be single by the way she's a
fun awesome hilarious girl that guys
so you like you like know sports and
[ __ ] yeah she's athletic
i always say sofia and i are the dude in
the relationship always if a guy tries
to spend the night we're saying
no no get out or we're always leaving
if the guy's like oh do you want to
spend then i go no and i leave you
it's just every time but i don't know
are we [ __ ] girls no no
no cause you if you you're not lying
that's you're not lying you're not
but but we're starting but we're still
going on the dates
we're still being ourselves i mean
listen okay let me tell you something
if a guy wants he at the least he could
do if he want to [ __ ]
is feed you so you still going on a date
that's not saying you want to be with
him that's just saying like
this is just the formality right i'm
hungry you hungry we got to eat we got
to eat sometimes we got to eat right
we gotta eat we have to eat like we
can't like that's that's the thing that
i
i don't i like again we we in that
society like we put these parameters
around like what dating is and what
[ __ ] is what this is what that is
it's whatever you want to do as long as
you're just keeping it 100.
yeah i have actually a question then
because i'm kind of seeing this guy and
if
it's been it's pretty early on we've
been on like five dates i'm kind of into
him but i don't know how to tell if he's
being a fuckboy or not because i can i
want to be cuffed
okay and i want to be really you like
him i like him i mean i i
we we get along i mean i wouldn't have
you guys been into me yet no
no and it's i'm one of those people i
kind of wait a bit but that's the
problem also so that's why i think i'm a
[ __ ] girl because i
emotionally get them and then i think
about it like oh wait i don't in a
girl's mind
we always think oh if you give it up too
soon they're going to lose interest
no the chase is gone the excitement's
gone the mystery is gone whether we [ __ ]
on the first night or the 40th night
the same interest will be there
regardless then what's the chase like
why would guys keep chasing even after
cause
you have to make guys do love a
challenge it's a yeah we in a in a way
though
okay like it's like this you could be
like be
be don't like it's
be hard but not be impossible okay like
you know what i'm saying like like don't
you be hard can you give an example
okay like okay like
something in your 20s a girl did that
you were like at your fuckboy
mm-hmm
this chick is someone i actually want to
see again regardless of
what my mentality is all right so i had
a girl um that i met in houston
and uh i [ __ ] her on the night i met
her right
but we just had a great
conversation conversations before and
after sex where i was like
okay this could be something who wants
here i want to see her again
and then she was like yo like as much as
i would love to see you again and blah
blah blah the reality is i live in
houston
you live in los angeles i have a child
i'm not moving
right you're not moving uh so how about
it just be when you come here
and you you see me i see you if we're
both single
she's straight up straight up straight
up women beat her on the [ __ ] thing
that's not [ __ ] girl [ __ ] so like in
your case with this guy
right yeah like this guy you're seeing
right now you like him i like him but i
don't know
how to tell whether or not he's being
how how would it would okay give me give
me some of the thing
okay he's an athlete okay is he a pro is
he like a famous
no famous but we're not fake but he's
a well-known team team okay okay you
don't have to disclose information
yeah he's always listening okay sorry so
he played he's an athlete yeah he plays
he plays a sport yeah
for a professional team yes that's a
good team or they're just
they're a good team yeah okay so they're
good teams and they are they are high
profile teams yeah
okay yeah okay so we'll leave it at that
all right all right now my question is
what what what makes you feel like he's
he you he's being a [ __ ] boy
because i can't read him i think the
things he does so that's number one
let's start there do not try to read men
oh all right
sis so don't can i do that that's cool
perfect so do not try to read men
okay do not try that that's like because
i try to i try to read women
and it's like because you don't because
you guys are ever evolving well yeah we
feel like
every time you guys are ever evolving so
you know you can't i can't i can't
read you so you're trying you're that's
your first mistake you're trying to read
them don't try to read them
he is who he is i'm an overthinker
that's the problem yeah don't overthink
it like he is who he is now
don't judge the fact that he's a
professional athlete he he may not be a
fuckboy because he's an athlete but
that's true
but he might rap that
every entertainer has that right like
what i'm saying so the question is how
do you take him for face value
you know what i'm saying right you're
trying to believe who he who i guess who
he is
yeah who he's showing you right all
right now here's how you
learn who like learned what he's doing
right like what are the differences that
you would see from a fuckboy versus a
guy that actually
on a date how how much interest does he
show you
he doesn't text unless it's the day
before or the day of
us hanging out but but he
plans very well thought out dates for
you okay well thought out
type of [ __ ] where brings a blanket to
the beach has an entire picnic set up
i mean he he goes but that doesn't mean
that doesn't mean anything that doesn't
mean
he could emotionally be playing me that
no no no i don't say he's gonna be
emotionally playing here's my here's my
thing yeah
sometimes guys go the extra mile because
they know other guys aren't
like think about you guys are beautiful
women right anybody he also knows
our last name is stallone so he's not
gonna all i'm not not saying that
there's gonna be a difference but that
does happen sometimes
it happens all the time okay it happens
all the time like don't listen
you know people people act like you know
like oh like like in the 1800s
if you had a certain last name you knew
what time it was if your last name was
carnegie if your last name was
rockefeller if you like
it you're in your mind you're like oh
you related and you find out they aren't
and you're like
right all right i gotta you get what i'm
saying so he knows that he can't just
take you to [ __ ] water or fat burgers
there's a standard you need yeah like
come on man you can't take rocky's
daughter
just can't do that even though i got
asked to get fat burgers yeah like
that's the same thing the same guy asked
me to get fat burger and then ghosted
both of us
but here's the thing that's [ __ ] with
you but here's the thing though but now
just but but but
some guys don't even know sometimes fat
burger works
by the way it does it works for me
that's the difference between sophia and
i she holds these guys to a standard
which is why she always has a better
right long-term relationship all around
good guy i don't expect much from people
so when they do buy me dinner
i'm like oh my god you're not letting me
split it i don't have to pay for
i no no that should be so here's the
thing so because he does these nice
things
on dates doesn't mean he's into you what
is it like
before and after the date what is it
like
during the week what is it does he text
you and just say hey i'm thinking about
it no
then he's not that interested see thank
you
i'm just going to be honest i said that
if he's
if he's not if he's not hitting you like
yo if i like you
and i mean i don't know i forget his
name that's well well
will what's up will how you doing will i
do is it will do y'all bring
in there yeah well yes you you you you
beat a girl
right yeah if you can't stop thinking
about it you're gonna let her know
i conversation is like i'm desperate to
find any way to talk to them as much as
i possibly can
i feel like from what i've heard from
this conversation up until this point
you're more about the
emotional connection the conversation
because because that's where i
now my 20s i went like that you did have
a podcast episode that was called
personality doesn't make me hard
yeah yeah that's how it yeah i mean
that's just it does me too
person make me hard personalities like i
mean yeah personalities keep me
yeah your titties and your ass and your
face
[Laughter]
so let's just say i got [ __ ] over by a
[ __ ] boy is there something
women or girls should do that would be
the best way to execute it or just kind
of cut it off and leave it you got to go
through it
yeah i just leave it yeah you got to go
through it you got to go you got it you
got to feel that i feel like a lot of
women end up being petty or like posting
too much on like
texting have you ever had that when a
woman has taken it to social media
i had regarding you i had a girl
recently like women take rejection
really
hard men take it really hard too with
egos
men and women no no you're right men and
women you know what men and women take
rejection differently
yeah men take rejection like like one
thing i notice you know first thing
there's women who are actually getting
killed
for telling a guy no i don't want to
give you my number right fellas i'm
gonna look in the camera if you listen
to this podcast and you watch this
and you are out here you know condoning
that kind of [ __ ] you
all right we we listen when a woman says
no
it means no there's no there's no why
there's no if's answer
just take the l bro right there's other
girls that'll like you
there's someone out there there's
somebody out there you ain't you know
what i'm saying like just because she
said
you ain't live you live the fight
another day right you know what i'm
saying why do you think men take it so
personally though
because when you say no right it kind of
makes us feel like we ain't fine or
handsome
you know what i'm saying like it's a
self-esteem thing yeah you know like if
i walk up to you and say hey how you
doing my name's clint i would love to
take you out i'm approaching you the
right way and you're just like hey
i have a boyfriend yeah or not even just
let's just say you just like hey i'm not
interested
like we take that like oh she doesn't
think i'm cute or something like that
it's like nah maybe she just
maybe she's just maybe she's just having
a bad day or maybe there's
thousands of reasons why you don't want
it but guys we internalize it now
girls on the other hand women flip
you guys get upset you guys take it you
guys take it personal
yeah you guys take it like there's
something wrong with me mm-hmm and it's
like no like okay give you an example
this girl
uh she shot her shot she she's like hey
i would love you know and i'm just like
hey
i'm not interested in you romantically
right i said that
and she took it like no you're like this
is why like you rather date the [ __ ]
girls and blah blah blah that's like no
no no it's not that
i just don't want you um
but that doesn't mean so that's the
thing that's i don't like knowing that
about that guy like he probably isn't
that interesting like what am i doing
there's nothing wrong with you so it's
not true i'm fine
i'm funny you aren't you but but but
that but but you are funny you are
charming you are
you do have a great personality you are
beautiful like yeah but
you're not you're just not his nice girl
like think about it like this
think about it like this when i just got
done telling guys
no means no right right and ladies you
don't need
you don't need you don't need to give
these guys an explanation
right why can't it be the same thing why
does it have to be you
maybe it's just where he is in life
don't forget about it a lot of guys
don't want to really be in relationships
either
i would love to see you in action in
high school
oh i would be a fly on there you know
it's crazy in high school man
uh so there was two phases of me in high
school though so like 9th and 10th grade
i was this tough guy in high school i
thought i was a thug
i thought i was like you play sports
well i played baseball that wasn't like
a resp
like i remember from philly like nobody
care about that that's a good sport it
is but
it's all like it's not like a badass
yeah like it's not basketball it's not
football and you gotta make on black
like
they want me to play football basketball
like i should be a pitcher dad
yeah but my dad's the one who put me on
baseball you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah so i played baseball but like
that's not getting [ __ ] like
you know what i'm saying like baseball
like come on so um
yeah but um no but in ninth and tenth
grade i thought i was a tough guy blah
blah blah but in 11th 12th grade i
ended up switching schools and i was in
a different environment and that changed
my life because i was able to be myself
um
and in high school like yeah that's what
i was being a fuckboy
lying to girls [ __ ] right and that
lasted until like my mid to late 20s
how do you finesse a [ __ ] boy what if
i'm really into a [ __ ] i'm not talking
about this guy just in general
is there a way or something girls do
that can make it almost
a little bit more beneficial on their
side you have to know
what you're dealing with so like so
again let's say let's say you're like
hypothetically speaking let's say i'm
like into you and you're a [ __ ] boy
right so let's say you're into me let's
like me right now let me right now like
this is non-fuck boy clint
okay let's say you're into clint right
now at 33 or whatever right yeah
and you say clint i'm into you blah blah
blah blah blah and i say all right so if
i'm into youtube blah blah blah blah
blah right
but now we both ask each other what do
we what do you want though
and you say clint you know i want to be
in a relationship blah blah blah blah
and i say sofia
i just want to be single i want to be
out here right this is how you
finesse the situation you say to
yourself
okay but i do like his company and i do
like hanging out with him and i do find
him attractive he may you know right
right and then you find out oh man he
has a good dick
you have to it's called a boundary so
like this wall right here
you have to create it so that you don't
get into a certain space
to where you're falling for a situation
that you know is not beneficial it's not
going to work out for you
and also things though but also
sometimes relationships evolve too
though just because i tell you i don't
want a relationship
doesn't mean that there's no potential
for future right but that's why you guys
keep having these conversations
right almost so you get emotionally
attached with him and then he actually
starts to see you in a different light
because there's not the pressure
right and then but then here's also this
though keep asking questions
so like let's say we've been [ __ ] for
a month sophia and then a month later
like you remember a month ago i didn't
want to relationship but a month later
you're like clint
i'm really like feeling you like you
know blah blah blah
i need to i might need to need some
space from this but then i tell you
no i feel the same way now
now we're but we've communicated right
you gave me the opportunity to
you asked the question before you you
know what i'm saying like no totally
if you feel like so like i've had
situations where there's girls that i've
felt all damn near fell in love with but
i knew she didn't want to be in a
relationship right and i said hey
i feel like our relationship's changing
do you feel the same she's like no and
i'm like okay well
i have to fall back paul backfit and
she's okay with that
because we're adults and we're talking
about yeah i
am all for a woman dming a guy first do
you think that that comes off a little
bit cocky
so what would you if you can you write
me a dm right now
that maybe you or someone else would
respond to be like oh damn she's funny
if a girl dms me first yeah right what's
a solid message
i mean for for and i'm just saying for
me i like straight up like you know
like i've had like i mean i get dms all
the time girls are just like hey you're
like what's up
right like i think you i think like guys
guys
don't admit this but every guy in this
studio that's listening to this podcast
right now
we love compliments from women like it's
one thing when you say nice shoes bro
like my man right here who's
looking at the camera i actually like
your sneakers nice shoes bro
that's a cool compliment right yeah
that's a cool compliment right or
well nice glasses i love your glasses
right i like your shirt yeah i like your
pen
thank you yeah yeah exactly it was a
cool compliment right but sophia
let's say you don't know will never met
wild day in your life so and you say
wow you're [ __ ] cute
his day is made he won't admit that
guys we don't we don't we don't well
you're adorable oh my god
no no you can't say adorable no
women don't like compliments from guys
that are creepy so we don't
like you're sexy you're you're [ __ ]
like we don't
y'all don't like those kind of
compliments that's true you like inner
compliments like like if we're talking
to you and
we say to you or like if we notice
something about you something that
normally people like let's say like
like if i notice like your eyelashes
yeah
you're like wow sophia you have
beautiful long eyelashes wow you're like
because you do things you know you know
what i'm saying like like if i'm looking
at you and i'm and i'm complimenting
something yeah
women like vote because that means
you're paying attention right
men like to feel sexy because we never
we're not y'all been sexualized since
you were
10. the moment you start growing breasts
and ass
think about it like you came back to
school growing up and you're like
like somebody's probably like wow she
grew up you know what i'm saying like
girls don't notice when our balls drop
wait we're not asking you to drop your
pants and like check it out no but
yeah like when i was 16 like no girl
ever i gotta write this bit down this is
that's
like no girl ever said like wow like
look at look at that dick right here
so you want to feel a little bit sexual
not sexualized
yes yes all right yes
good yeah yes
nobody hasn't been trying to [ __ ] me
since i was 12.
so we're bored we're over we don't want
to hear those comments yeah you're done
like yeah now you're like talk to me
about my personality talk to me about
my my like oh you like oh like would you
ever find out you like like
like you ever you ever you ever liked
the same music as a guy like
the exact same yeah it's oh it's amazing
right it is right it's a great
compliment
it's like because now he he he's
complimenting your taste in music yeah
then what i'm saying totally women like
those guys no tell me
i'm sexy [ __ ] boys are fun
but let me tell you they're funny boys
are funny
they are fun they're not boring i enjoy
the chaos i love
i love being it sounds [ __ ] up but i
love being [ __ ] over because i want to
do it back and it's just game and it's
fun
you're toxic
but let me tell you i end up always
being
good at winning yeah but in the end like
i'm always giving them more than they
gave me
right right right but you know if
they're if they're being a little bit
shady you're
you do it back i don't like to be taking
advantage you don't like to lose
but let me tell you tell me why clint
that the ones that [ __ ] you over the
most is the hardest to get over when it
should just be like okay
i'm done with you we should just move on
you feel like you lost nobody likes
accepting
loss right losing sucks we need to start
this group chapter i know because i have
so many more questions
listen you have my like she got my
number i'll give you my number when we
we leave here after we do whatever we do
and you guys are like
you're like y'all y'all my friends like
we cool now you're awesome we're
legit cool now oh i love give any final
piece of advice to leave to our
listeners
just about from the advice from a
fuckboy or former
fuckboy that used to know what it was
and now retired
always pay attention to what you see
not what you hear so you see these
actions a lot of times like
ladies this is for ladies trust your
intuition
a lot of times you're right a lot of
times you have a bad feeling about this
guy
mm-hmm you are right right do not
stick around if you feel like you have a
bad feeling
and that goes for men too like you ever
feel like fellas you're like damn like
no this just seems too good to be true
it probably is
you know what i'm saying that's true and
ladies if he's like like again with this
athlete
you know he's he's great on dates
but outside of that it's just yeah right
you're right i know that's my instinct i
probably finally start listening to it
for once in my life right
well thank you so much absolutely so
much fun plug
all your socials yeah absolutely yeah
you guys can follow me my name is at
clint coley at c-l-i-n-t
c-o-l-e-y um i have a podcast i also
have a podcast page it's called advice
from a fuckboy
uh make sure y'all listen to that
download subscribe whatever you want to
do and then also
last but not least uh september 1st i
have a show that's
coming out on facebook watch it's called
the world series of spades
uh basically it's basically like the
world series of poker but spades so we
got 16 episodes of that man
and i don't know if anybody here if
anybody happens to play
we've spades appreciated all of the
advice for the time
thank you so much for any time no doubt
from all of us here at the show thanks
for staying on wax
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts
spotify or podcastone.com follow your
hosts
at sophia stallone and at sistine
stallone and be sure to follow the show
at unwaxed podcast your producer is will
sterling
we'll see you next week